oh thank you so much I going to talk
today and I'm going to try to actually
go through my actual material relatively
quickly because I really would like to
be able to leave some time for QA and I
hope that this stuff I have to talk
about will promote some I'm actually
some of the things I'm very much
interested in getting feedback from the
audience about directions to go the
thing I'm going to talk about is a
library that we have here let me go
through the first couple slides where I
say that I'm that in Continuum's great
and I carry advertising here and run
anaconda and these are other stuff and I
did a bunch of things that Brian
summarized as well but this is what I'm
going to talk about we have a product
that currently is part of our
proprietary for our commercial customers
called il pro this is just the
description that's on the website you
can go to you know continuum I oh and I
don't know the exact URL to that but you
know / dock / io pro or something and
it'll tell you what that it does this
that it's this library for speeding up
access to big data sets so that's great
and it's kind of cool but of course its
proprietary and part of this talk is to
let everybody know that we're going to
be opening up and releasing as free
software this component the part of oh
ok you can install it today if you do it
today it will install fine of course you
have to have Conda but it'll when you
run it it'll give you a little nags
about the fact you have a 30 day trial
period hopefully within 30 days it'll
have moved open source anyway and if it
takes more than 30 days sorry but you
know it will be in the near future but
the particular part actually that I want
to release is this thing called text
adapter I'm primarily in my job a
continuum do training so I you know go
to the customer sites and teach
scientists about learning python and
learning design
stacked numpy and scifi and pandas and
matplotlib and bouquet and ask and
things like that and one of the
trainings I did recently was about this
commercial library we have for one of
our customers that has bought it about
IO pro and sort of in the course of
doing that I you know taught it I got a
good understanding for the first time of
what this software does and you know but
I also found some bugs and rough edges
in it and decided that rather than
document the bugs I should just fix the
bugs so I think I'm now the official
maintainer of this particular library
which is which is great if it does cool
stuff and hopefully I'll oversee i'm
pretty sure i will this you know open
sourcing of this part of it called text
adapter and this is a description that's
more or less what's on the website to of
what it does but what did this text
adapter part that i really want to get
into the world an open source it gives
you a way to deal with textual data
sources so csb maybe Jason files maybe
you know fixed width or sort of you know
funny formats and do it in a way that's
much faster than you would do without
using this adapter it's a library but
there's a bit of a trade-off here which
I think will be kind of obvious to
people as I talk about it is at a
certain point if you have a data source
you know there's lots and lots of things
that are published as csv files from
public sources from private sources
whatever and maybe there are huge files
there gigabytes of CSV or terabytes and
at a certain point if this is data that
you're working with all the time you
don't want to use our adapter and access
it that way because you want to put it
into a proper database or you know maybe
a key value store or maybe a no SQL or
maybe SQLite or you know this is
something that can speed it up a lot and
I'll show you some examples here but
it's not
sort of the optimal permanent thing I
don't want to oversell it in that way on
the other hand I think that for data
scientists a lot of what we do is not
really dealing with bait data on a
permanent basis you I have some examples
you'll see later that I get from the
health insurance marketplace some stuff
that's government data that was released
about all the things about you know
after before and after the ACA and the
consequences of you know the kind of
health insurance people have so this is
a cool data source in its has lots of
useful information but maybe in your job
you just need to get a picture of what's
going on with this data and it's not
something that you're going to on a
daily basis you know keep running jobs
against and you know analyzing over and
over in different ways and it is sort of
some work to put it into your permanent
database setup and you know define your
schemas and whatever provision dis space
or the servers or whatever it is that's
necessary so on the other hand if you're
just going to you know read through it
once and never do anything again
probably this is overkill too so it's
sort of the intermediate space you're
dealing with this data and maybe you're
going to access it tens of times maybe
hundreds of times to get some picture of
what's going on and then maybe you're
going to do some other exploration of
another data set that you know comes
from the same place or somewhere else
and for that particular use with very
little overhead I think text adapter can
get you something very nice in several
respects of having a more convenient API
to the state and particularly a much
faster API to the data and one of the
key things that does I think maybe the
most important is am I not loud enough
okay I feel booming
test okay
okay that loud enough for people so the
thing we can do is we can create an
index on the data this slide just says
that but i want to show some examples of
how it works so maybe i have some data
that is could be on a local disk or on a
you know sort of semi local network
drive or it could be in the cloud it
could be on s3 somewhere else we don't
yet have the interfaces for but i kind
of hope once we open up we'll have
interfaces for other cloud services but
anyway s3 is hugely popular and we have
that now so this is a fairly small file
and maybe it won't show things to the
best effect but you know here on s3
there is this data from the health
insurance stuff called plan attributes
that has 77,000 lines and there's a 95
megabyte file okay you could load that
into memory that's not absurd to do but
i just want to show you the api this
point at this point and i'll show you a
little bit with some larger data so we
can just create this adapter object that
access is you know with the key
information and the bucket name and all
the usual stuff and s3 access but then
when we open it we're going to generate
an index of course we have to do a
linear scan through the whole thing once
to create the index we're not going to
magically find out where things are but
once we've created the index things are
going to go much much faster and the
problem here of course is that with data
that has fixed size records it's really
easy to do a calculated offset with CSV
data or JSON data or you know some other
delimiter or other formats it's not easy
you have no idea how long one row of CSV
data is and so therefore you have no
idea how much you would jump for an
offset and even if you made a rough
guess and tried to jump you know
approximately where you think it is you
have no way of knowing how many lines
into it you are because you don't know
all the lines that you skipped over
maybe this is obvious to everybody what
I'm saying but our software does some
stuff behind the scene
so for example this is what I ran on my
computer is I ran the little script to
read the plans I did it once I did it
again and I go from taking one minute to
take me 15 seconds so 4 times speed up
here if this was a larger data source it
would be a larger speed up but I'm still
going to be somewhat limited because the
way as three works in particular has
blocks of data so you can't just read to
an exact seek position you still have to
read a block but if there were you know
a hundred times as many blocks you're
still just reading that particular block
out of the data so you probably you know
if the data were ten times as big the
first number would be ten times as large
but the second would still be 15 seconds
so that could be a substantial win when
I say here that it's pretty good but we
can actually do even better i think on
local file systems i've been benchmarked
every permutation possible but i have
one here where i have some data it's on
my local file system again it's from
this health insurance marketplace set
and in this case I'm actually putting it
in a gzip file so i can press it because
i don't want to spend a lot of time
storing it and there's a nice property
of geez if algorithm where regenerates
the compression table periodically
throughout it so you're still not
getting exact seek you have to seek to
the you know block where the new
compression table starts but you're
skipping most things and this is much
bigger data this is 13 million lines
instead it comes to 110 megabytes
compressed or two gigabytes if it were
uncompressed of the raw data so this is
maybe not quite big data yet but it
we're at least getting into medium size
data maybe I should have for the talk
tested against something that was bigger
than this and I think the effects would
be more dramatic but what we find here
is again it's pretty much the same code
that we saw on the previous slide we're
opening up not the s3 text adapter but
the text adapter that particular file
yes it's compressed it's a CSV file and
we're going to generate the index and
we're going to jump
to a particular row or actually a
particular range of five rows in this
case but it could be a larger number
it's near the end so I'm jumping to row
10 million through you know five more
than that out of the 13 million rows if
I had just used yeah you know the CSV
module I have two linear scan through
everything to get there if I had tried
to import this into a pandas dataframe
well probably I have enough memory for
this one but you know if we're bigger I
might not have enough memory but this
will work on unlimited size data and
what we get there is quite a bit more
win it's about 20 times faster and all I
had to do was just wrap that around that
adapter around it and then what I can do
is use a slicing syntax to pull off a
collection of rows and get numpy array
as a result optionally you'll see in a
second I can make that a pandas
dataframe but this is a way to look at
chunks of the data at a time and put
them in these familiar interfaces as
numpy arrays or as panda data frames and
take advantage of this indexing to get
later parts of it very quickly so you
imagine you know I repeatedly for some
reason I'm interested in row 10 million
or the region around there of the data
and I can do it quite quickly repeatedly
once I've generated this index and i'm
not sure if it was evident in the s3
example but the index i generated was on
my local disk even though the data
continues to live out there in the cloud
so you know i have local disk access for
that and it's a small file it's you know
whatever maybe kilobytes or something
for the index file and just to show
something off on you know my particular
computer with the cpu and the number of
cores and everything else i have
accessing the data near the end is
actually faster than just the you know
gunzip operation all by itself so just
decompressing takes more time than
jumping to the row near the end
about a little over twice as long in
this particular example but in this
stuff I showed you above I actually
cheated a little bit but the way I
cheated actually gets to some more
features that we have although it also
gets to some things that I know I want
to enhance about text adapter one of the
things text adapter does is it looks the
data you're reading at the particular
slice or offset that you're looking at
and tries to do some type inference
about the data and the type inference is
much less smart than it should be so it
often makes the wrong guesses and if it
makes the wrong guesses unfortunately
the failure mode is currently not that
great either but you know whatever I
filed an issue against it i'm going to
fix it so you get trace back spacing or
exactly him you don't want to see those
but you can manually specify data types
that you're reading for what it's worth
if you were to take a huge slice it
would probably make a much better guess
because you'd have seen representations
of all the data within a particular
column and that would be kind of nicer
but in my example I was just taking the
five rows out of it but there was a line
above in the code that I showed you that
had this and I just imported what data
types was from another module that I
didn't show you but this is what was in
it something like this is that you know
after I got a few of these trace backs
and I took a look through what was going
wrong I decided to assign data types to
particular fields so column 0 that's a
4-byte floating-point and for the rest
of the stuff i just said these are just
the object data type completely generic
there python objects that works I mean
anything is going to be fine as a Python
object whatever you happen to read I
mean it's gonna be a string basically
but it's not the absolute best because
you're probably going to want to do some
you know computation and filtering and
all the things you do in the analysis so
you probably want more specific data
types I mean you see that in the column
0 here
I've given it you know floating point of
a certain number of bytes but this was a
cheap way to do it by making a lot of
stuff object type but let's take a look
at what we can do if we want to massage
it a little bit this this rate is the
big one this is the one with 13 million
rows so the timing is maybe a little bit
interesting you can use in the adapter
object the you know pandas style of
indexing where you present a list of
different columns that you're interested
in looking at so this is going to pull
row I guess in this case it's row nine
million rather than 10 million and I'm
only interested in those columns whose
headers are these several things listed
issue or ID in business year and so on
this particular the other one I think
had 140 some columns and this one I
think just has 40 some columns but in
any case this is the syntax that is
familiar to people who have worked with
pandas or you know x-ray or other things
that are kind of familiar as a way of
accessing data frame II kind of things
so it has some familiarity in the
interface and what we see in this
somewhat naive approach to reading it we
very quickly I mean here in a tenth of a
second not even the one second we saw
reading the range in most of the savings
some of it's because we're only reading
one row as opposed to five but the other
part of it is because we're only looking
at some of the columns so it's I think
this is very reasonably fast a tenth of
a second it's not a huge delay in most
of your processing obviously if you're
taking a much larger range of rows or
more columns then it will slow down
somewhat but what we have as a result of
doing this indexing first into the
collection of columns and then into a
particular row in this double indexing
on the screen is some values and then
some data types that are associated with
them you see that the first one is just
generic object data type which is not
great and the others are unsigned in
jurors 8-bit I mean eight byte which is
the fallback if it sort of doesn't know
too much which means it was just empty
or zeros in those particular location
that's okay i mean we pulled off the
data quickly we could process it as is
right there but actually that's not the
best way to deal with the data once i
look at it a little more closely i know
a little bit more about the kind of data
that i encounter in those columns so for
example business year isn't a generic
object it's a year it's you know you
know 2008 or something like that and
that seems like it should fit perfectly
fine in an unsigned 16-bit into me so
why bother spending more memory on it
once I floated it into the in memory
array and column 16 you notice that i
can use either the name or the numeric
offset which corresponds to the one
that's called couple is column 16 i want
to be a four-point floating for by
floating point number so again i do the
same thing in this case i just pull off
the second row which the index doesn't
matter at this point because it wouldn't
take any real time to get there and i
get some other values but you see that
their data typed in a more interesting
and appropriate way and in particular
way that uses less memory to hold each
row so if i were to not just read one
row here but read say get the million
rows i was interested in I could
probably now start to fit it in memory
more conveniently with the smaller data
types that are more appropriate and I
just mentioned in sort of the footnote
that probably issuer ID doesn't really
need eight bytes it could probably be
some smaller number to store that number
but it will just leave it as that for
now but there's some more we can do when
we create these adapters we can actually
create an adapter that massages the data
as it comes into the adapter or when
it's you know
we actually access it so when I looked
at this one that was the plan attributes
the one that was not so large but it was
over there on s3 I noticed something
about the fields that were actually the
ones that were failing and I just said
these are generic objects and I saw that
they had these particular values for a
couple of those field numbers and they
you know create some ideas in my mind
about what they probably mean as data
types I could of course look a little
deeper and look at more than just the
row where it was a failure and a variety
of things to make sure that I'm really
on the right track but you know to me
yes is probably either going to be yes
in that field or it's going to be no or
maybe it's going to be empty um but
essentially I'm that's it looks like a
representation of a boolean value to me
and this other thing you know dollar
sign 1667 well that really looks like
floating point number but it's not going
to be parsed in the type inference as a
floating point number because the dollar
sign isn't you know the signature of the
initializer to float in numpy floater
python float but you know it should be
easy to get the right thing out of that
and similarly with the percentage and
the other things so if I look at the way
that the data looks as strings I can
probably massage it into my in-memory
representation into something that's a
bit better and the way I do that is by
creating one of these converter
functions or a couple of these converter
functions in this case so I've written a
little function that I could reuse on
many columns that's yes to bullion and
it's just if the string is yes and I
decide the lowercase version of it to be
a little bit more general oh that code
is broken um there's a bug there that's
sad anyway it should be lower case yes
in the in the code pretend that I had
typed my letters in the correct case I
could set a converter for that
particular field of that function that
as it was read into
centrally an umpire array or a pandas
dataframe you would automatically
massage it into a boolean value in this
case by doing that comparison or on
column 63 here I'm giving the number
rather than the name I could do just a
lambda function in line or I'm massaging
it and in this case I'm you know taking
off the percentage sign and dividing by
a hundred because it's something I
expect to be a percentage so then I want
to set those field types to the
particular things I'm interested in so
be for boolean and f4 to buy floating
point and I imagine if I had written the
code right once I get the results of
those couple columns number 43 which
happens to be dental only plan and then
or no sorry I number 63 as issue or
actual and 43 is dental only whatever um
again i'm just showing the selection
using either numbers or names and i'm
pulling off this row 70,000 which was
again near the end of this particular
file and i had created the index that's
on my local disk this is happening now
although there's no timing information
here so I get some values that are
minimally represented as a boolean and a
short floating point and i'm pretty sure
that when i was trying to test this this
should show as a one rather than zero if
my converter function had been correct
so that's a thing we can do to get our
data into sort of cleaned up into this
adapter object another way you can
approach it is you can use regular
expression patterns so maybe you want to
read in your data and you know maybe
it's kind of delimited but there's
things between the delimiter zh that are
actually sort of different components of
the data or there's other things that
are kind of or maybe that's not really
delimited at all but it is line oriented
you can write a regular expression to
pull out the parts of the data that are
interesting line by line and present it
in the same
uniform interface that you know
ultimately is to get some part of it
into numpy arrays in memory so here's a
way I probably should have tried to put
these on the same screen you can see
it's a messy pattern there's you know
the dollar sign thing and the percentage
sign thing and then there's the state
spelled out in a sort of ugly way that's
not going to be easy to convert to a
real date time object but this is the
pattern oh and by the way that was
actual Nasdaq published data those are
two lines of it but I didn't make that
up for the example that's real world
data so what I'm looking for is the
things that are in the reg ex groups you
see that some of the stuff is surrounded
by these parentheses in the regular
expression and others isn't and so the
stuff that isn't in any of the groups
we're just throwing out we're not
interested in that data we're discarding
it but the stuff that is in the groups
we're going to use as the data that
we're reading in so we read something
that is one decimal digit then we're
going to read and we're going to ignore
the dot and then we're going to read
them a couple decimal digits to and then
we're going to read a bunch of anak here
I just arbitrarily said 0 dash nine
rather than this little backslash d and
you know one or more of those and
discard the percentage sign and you see
how it's broken up here and the parser
we're using here is not CSV it's reg ex
and it's that particular regular
expression in my little thing i showed
you i don't have field name headers so
i'm not going to try to use those and
we're not going to bother inferring
types we're going to set them explicitly
here in the next slide in particular we
want those types to be you know to bite
integer to byte unsigned integer anyway
there's several things for the several
columns and we want the names of those
columns to be dollars sense percentage
and month where you know discarding some
of the stuff that was in the line but
we're interested in others of it and
then when we in this case to an empty
slice into the whole thing
because it's actually small data and I
can do that but I sort of don't well
this feels like an attractive nuisance
and unfortunately it's actually in some
of the official documentation currently
of io pro where it says empty slice to
show examples but if you're actually
dealing with the kind of data sizes
where it matters to be using text
adapter Rio pro then taking the empty
slice is a bad idea because it's too big
for memory what you're reading so I'm
not sure what API would avoid that maybe
issue a warning when you do it or I
don't know but you see the data we're
pulling off here is some you know
integer dollars an integer sense and the
percentage sign is a floating points and
I probably should divided that by 100
but anyway and a month is a string
that's up to 10 characters so we're
massaging data as are reading it in and
what we're pulling off is data frames or
what we're pulling up sort of
immediately is a raise but you can
convert those into data frames now you
could do this where you take that empty
slice and you just say make the whole
thing a data frame but again that's sort
of crazy because the data is too big and
that's why we're using this library and
to fit in memory but this is a better
way to write it in the second line
that's not it's not as a string but the
actual thing is just you know create the
numpy array object that you know is a
certain slice of a reasonable amount of
the data it could be more than two but
you know a million not a billion sort of
thing and convert that into a data frame
and it fits in memory and you can do all
your panda stuff with it and then you
know we see what the pandas looks like
so there's a bunch more stuff that's
going to be that isn't text adapter and
will be in the free software release it
can deal with Jason stuff and then I
didn't really show examples but slicing
does the stuff you'd expect with strides
and negative indexing and all of that
you can do a couple other setup method
calls about how missing data will be
filled in like if there's any you know
just an empty field in it then just
treat that as some certain value you can
do some introspection of these adapters
to find out what was inferred and what's
happening with them but what I want to
talk about in the remaining time which
is not as much as I hoped so go even
faster is two things both some ideas for
what to do next like in this time scale
of it becoming hopefully a community
project and then some general comments
about open source and what is our you
know how does our private company who
really does have a commitment to open
sourcing the software we do at least as
appropriate as possible how do we deal
with you know the strategy of doing it
so that just says what I just said so
one of the things that indexing that I
just showed you is very limited it's
just it's just an index into the various
positions of the rows which allows a
fast seek into something that's much
later but it's not database style
indexing where I actually you know
wanted index on numbers or string values
or things like that and we could do that
I mean we could add more kinds of
indices that were more sophisticated but
on the other hand it's sort of a
trade-off I mean I'm not going to write
something that's as good as one of the
popular you know i'm not going to
rewrite postgres or MySQL or SQLite to
do everything it does based on CSV files
and if I tried to it would be much worse
than those implementations and you know
if it's a case where you really want all
of that you should probably just be
using one of these things but on the
other hand there's this you know that's
in between case I said you're using the
data a little bit but not that
repeatedly so maybe we still want some
better indexing and I'm trying to decide
and try to get some questions like how
much
I can be I mean I think this first thing
I say like just looking at the strings
and just you know where is everywhere
that the name Smith occurs in this data
set and you know store that as a you
know a mapping from the particular key
to all the different rows where it
occurs and maybe one level of
indirection but that could be very fast
to get something like that so I think
this equality indexing for a field it is
very straightforward I could do that
well maybe I could do a little bit more
of the Panda stuff I mean certainly I
know how to compute you know the lower
case of the string value of the thing
but then again exactly which
capabilities are there with
transformations that might get indexed
and something that's like fully general
I mean these are you know in pandas or
numpy you might write an expression of
you know of this sort very
straightforwardly but of course what
that's doing is it's doing a linear scan
through the data that can actually fit
in memory here we're imagining that
we're dealing with our gigabytes and
gigabytes of data and you can't fit it
all in memory and here you're just back
to linear scan I mean yes I could
support that syntax but just saying do a
linear scan the whole thing and there's
no speed up which is what we're going
for so I'm interested in your thoughts
about how far is feasible and worthwhile
to do given that if we go too far just
the advice should actually don't use
this youth database this you know
mentions predicate of indexing and stuff
I don't know the API that I would use
for this additional index and capability
are kind of skip through that how many
people in the room node ask moderately
well or reviews that hardly anybody I'm
going to sort of skip over this because
I want to talk about the open-source
thing a little bit desk is great and
it's open source it's not proprietary
it's mainly developed by continuum folks
and a bunch of these conferences a bunch
of our folks if given talks on it but
the idea of desk is it's it does a
number of things but it's a distribution
of tasks across either multiple cores or
multiple machines in the cluster
and it can read in data into as in a
blocked way so you have this huge data
set you read it into thousands of
different panda data frames but the
interface presented is unified so it's
as if you are operating on just one
pandas dataframe and it's really cool
what it can do and there's some overlap
between what this does and what that
does so but I think there's some
differences too for example there's no
concept of indexing and desk so I might
describe these as higher level lower
level but since desk isn't that familiar
i won't go on about that i do think
there's a way but again you're not from
that familiar with task of sort of
making these things play together so we
can take advantage of the indexing and
the reg ex patterns and stuff like that
that text adapter provides and make desk
behave better faster I'm going to skip
over the number stuff I think that we
can probably accelerate some of the
custom converter functions using number
which is a just-in-time compiler for
Python code I hope everybody's played
with that and again free software or
mostly produced by continuum go use it
and we tried this a long time ago a
couple years ago with a very early er
version of numba a very earlier version
of i/o pro and I don't know if it
actually ever worked but but it's not
currently supported by current number
because the idea is that you would need
to convert a string to some sort of
numeric thing and number doesn't
accelerate that now and here's just a
quick example like I might use in Arabic
numeral well pythons you know in
function knows how to deal with numerals
of other types other than you know
European numerals but maybe we could do
something like this if we already took
advantage of the converters to basic
numeric types and then did some
operation on them and we could get that
with number and maybe that's a thing we
do in the future if these can converter
are something that's very valuable to
people but basically I want to open it
up but let me go through the last couple
of things just really quickly I don't
get to decide this about the open
sourcing stuff I'm not I don't have a
seat in front of my title at continuum
but I am very interested in the right
strategy to do about this and I you know
I think this is something that really is
valuable to give back to the community
as a company while not undercutting our
ability to sell commercial software
which is a big part of our business and
I think I mean I curious if other people
have had a similar issue at their
companies but i think the probably the
best approach to do this is something
that I mean I call the ghost script
model but I'm old and that was people
probably don't even use that software
anymore but the model that they had was
the version that was released as free
software was always a version behind the
thing that the people who paid money
could have I know right oh yeah okay so
maybe that's the approach we take maybe
we release 1.9 the current version as
free but then to point always these cool
things that you know people don't get
without paying money for a certain
number of months or until the next
version or something but you know maybe
what does that mean if people contribute
back code to the community project and
how does the licenses work with maybe
more importantly how does the sense of
really participating in the community
and not exploiting it work and you know
that's the thing we have to think about
so that's basically I stop talking I
want at least a few minutes for people
to ask things
which which hopefully somebody wants to
do since I do you want to Mike in the
back or well the back was first we
should go to him that's you
what
rad
you know personally I think that
probably works I I'm not sure that
everybody and much of the people are
actually making an incision think that
works I mean but in my mind our big
corporate or big you know government
customers they don't want to github go
to github and worry about compiling the
scythe on code that's linked to some C
code that has some Python components and
making it work on their platform they
just want to type Conda install and you
know then it just looks at the license
key and yes they could do it without
paying money but you know they'd rather
just pay money than have hassle I'm not
sure the support issue I mean certainly
you know it could break and they want
support and they want prompt address of
those issues and that's sort of the red
red hat model pretty much but I actually
think the support issue is less than
just the convenience issue but that's
just that's my take i don't really know
for sure um friend
it lives well wherever you want to put
it but it is probably on your local disk
and it's small
you have to regenerate the index there's
a fun there's a method called create
index and you just you'd have to call
that again to actually do it if the CSV
file changes but I'm thinking that you
know for example i gave the you know the
health insurance marketplace data i
don't have the ability to change that I
mean I suppose I do when it's on my own
local hard drive but I really shouldn't
its data that's produced by someone else
and I have to take as a immutable
artifact and that's the scenario that I
think is most useful but there's a
method you can always call create index
again regenerate the index which of
course is linear scan through the whole
file and you know do the things you do
to generate an index
ok
what
yeah well okay so I don't think you want
to generate an SQLite file I actually oh
sorry the question was why not just
generate an SQLite file rather than try
to do my own funky indexing and I
actually on my own local disk here oh oh
that's actually the show tables I need
to exit sqlite and show you so I
actually did that on my system and I
should have probably benchmarked it and
see how it did I'm sure ask you lights
faster than any of this stuff but think
of the example where the data is
published at the end of a URL or on a
shared file system you don't control or
you know s3 bucket or something like
that I mean yes you can download it put
it on your local system generate the
SQLite file and access it much faster
but there are several steps involved in
doing that and if this is data that is
sort of trend not transient like in the
sense it's going to change transient the
sense that you're only going to use it
for a little while maybe you don't want
to do that and maybe you don't want to
allocate tens or hundreds of gigabytes
of disk space on your local storage for
this stuff that someone else is storing
for you on the other hand if you're
going to work with this data if you can
access the state of thousands of times
do that
the current position only index adds
essentially nothing to the linear scam
so it's the same amount of time it takes
to read the file in the first place
maybe a ten percent person I mean it's a
very small cost to do that now if I did
really complex indexing that did some
sort of function you know abstraction or
you know made the lowercase version of
everything or all the different
transformations are you defined index
based on some complex predicate or
conceivably that would take more time
I mean I know I'm overtime any way but
oh ok with that you can I take one more
from the back or am I'm cut off
I didn't and once we managed to get it
publicly released I welcome your
contribution to adding that parser no no
I'm not I mean I'm being a little
tongue-in-cheek but I'm really serious
that's part of them Bennett I think
that's great I you know dealt with data
that has that and you know maybe we'll
do it in-house if I I have time
basically but as a community project
that becomes possible when somebody has
a need for that sort of thing I think
it's an art